so here he is
he's 19 and he was murdered monday
morning wendy williams comes under fire
again
like like really like are you serious on
wednesday the daytime talk show host
introduced a segment about the death of
19 year old tick tock star swavey
by complaining that he had more
followers than her on tick-tock
but not on instagram i have no idea who
this is
neither does norman neither does one
person
in this building maybe sus does uh
do you know who swavy is
clap clap if you know who swaby is
okay sauce nah
it's not my it's not my cup of tea
the clapping eventually stopped which is
when wendy went on a minute long
discussion about the teen also known as
matima miller's
social media following he's a tick-tock
star he's got more followers than me
2.5 million on
tock but on instagram you have more
followers
[Applause]
well as my son kevin would say no one
uses instagram anymore
what and as far as tick tock i don't use
that
at all i don't know what that is i don't
want to be involved
then the 56 year old turned to a photo
of the young dancer and revealed he had
died
so here he is
he's 19 and he was murdered monday
morning swavey died from an apparent
gunshot wound in delaware wendy's moment
went viral with
many calling for the show which is in
its 13th season
to be canceled e.t has reached out to
the show for comment
[Music]
all this comes just days after wendy
received backlash for comparing her
failed marriage with
ex kevin hunter to tabitha brown's
marriage after the social media star
told her fans
that her recent successes have allowed
her husband chance to retire from his
job as a police officer with the lapd
after 15 years something she called a
quote
dream finally come true i was married to
one of those
you know i make the money and so on and
so forth
go live your dreams buy a business you
know stay with me but
go go go you see how that turned out
i predict that this marriage is going to
be on real rocky ground
in a moment live your dream shortly
after that segment aired
tabitha took to her instagram to respond
to wendy's comments
claiming her marriage was nothing like
the tv personality's marriage
when did the pain you must be in to feel
this way and i'm so sorry
but listen let me tell you this um 23
years i've been with my husband
yes uh broke for a very long time
together for a very long time
together succeeded
for the last couple of years together
tabitha ended the video praying for
wendy to find the same kind of love
she's experienced
and she captioned the clip quote keep
god
first this is my word and prayer for
wendy williams
and anyone else that doesn't understand
this type of love and support
god bless y'all when eti caught up with
wendy in january
she got candid about her nearly 22-year
marriage to her ex-husband
with whom she shares a 20-year-old son
kevin hunter jr
i stuck with my ex-husband
because we had a son if we didn't have
children i would have been out
you know i would have been out uh but we
had a son
and we were living my career was doing
better every year my career would do
better and every year
kevin would turn into more of a jerk and
the daytime talk show host
opened up about the future admitting she
knows her tv show won't last forever
i like doing something besides this talk
show because this is not going to last
forever
and being on tv in front of the camera
is fun
i love doing this but i'm realistic and
i know it's not going to last forever
i would like to go into the classroom i
would like to be a professor
i would like to get into that classroom
action and i would like to actually
start doing that before the talk show is
over and then keep it going
you know forever